It’s time for a clash of the titans: SCP-682, the
Hard to Destroy Reptile, SCP-106, the Old Man,
and SCP-953, the Polymorphic Humanoid.
This wasn’t even a Foundation cross-test:
Just an organic battle that occurred
during a massive containment breach.
SCP-953 and SCP-106 entered 682’s containment
chamber, at which point they all began staring at
each other, preparing for an attack. 106 began the
battle, sinking into the floor and grabbing 953,
trying to pull her into his pocket
dimension. She then grabbed 682,
resulting in all three of them being
pulled into the pocket dimension.
They all remained in there for five hours, before
returning, heavily injured from their fight.
106 returned to his chamber, 953 was recaptured by
Foundation personnel, and 682 regenerated its 67%
body mass loss. All three have refused
to speak about the incident since.